Sustenir's vision is to actually grow a more resilient future.
What we do is we grow incredible products...
...that does not only taste better than conventional farming,...
...but is actually 100 percent clean, free of pesticides,...
...and is actually more nutritious as well.
A lot of Singaporeans became a lot more aware about where their produce was coming from,...
...and a lot more concerned about the safety of their products.
I think for the Singapore government,...
...it was very much about the food resilience system that they've built.
Relying on neighboring countries, but when the border shut down, what do we do?
So, there's a big focus now on how do we get our productivity up.
Food security is a rising concern for countries...
...as weather pattern changes disrupt crops,...
...while a growing global population adds stress to food supply chains.
Today, less than 10 percent of Singapore's nutritional needs...
...are produced in the land-scarce country, which is smaller than New York City.
The country hopes to raise that figure to 30 percent by 2030...
...through smart land use and technology,...
...including investments in deep tech start-ups like agri-food.
All the agencies have really collaborated and come together...
...to help companies like Sustenir do the things that we're doing today.
And when we think about R&D, it's very expensive.
We, as a business, want to focus on bringing great products,...
...but we also have to think about how do we further improve the way that we're growing,...
...and so we can think about bringing down our cost and also broadening our product mix.